stuffed animals continue to be my score  50 cents a pop Dumbo Disney Store  Snuffaluffagus bang Olaf what and this  one's going to be a beast the FAO  Schwartz giraffe this is gonna be a good  one can I see the giraffe  no no it's not why not because it just  isn't just look at the face that one  looks sadder than the other one no look  at the patches on the eyes like it's not  the one that's gonna be it I may not be  it either  weird it's just Toys R Us it does yeah  so it is the FAO Schwarz Jeffrey it's  Jeffrey wow it's the 30 one just looked  it up Toys R Us FAO Schwarz combo 30  bucks paid 50 cents to say after eBay  fees just like a quick 20 bucks that's  just one of the things wait till I look  up the snuffle others that's such a  great line